you have a new really good reason to
watch the skills competition at NBA
Allstar we might witness probably the
best three-point shooting contest in
history but this time things are going
to run a bit different Steph Curry who's
the all-time NBA three-point leader will
square off against the WNBA three-point
Champion Sabrina yanes these two friends
have been itching to compete against
each other for a long time Steph called
out Sabrina while he was miked up during
pregame warm-ups and being the
competitor that Sabrina is she responded
by telling him to meet her at the
three-point line even though we know how
great of a shooter Steph is he still
doesn't hold the record for the most
points in a Three-Point Contest Sabrina
does and now we get to see who wins this
anticipated matchup